[Music]
Ballu rather Manon
Oh GRU 30% of G fuel if you entered the
code at the checkout only for a limited
time
damn I'm actually really good at this
Rick and do this guy's we're trying out
this new thing the role is very simple
Scott the dude falou writing if you want
to accept this challenge then all you
have to do it's very simple smash like
on this video go buy the entire stock of
G fuel but you get 30% off so you can
buy 30% more if you enter the code you
have to say P when you enter the code
now without further ado if you have done
this we can move on let's freakin do
this let's just yeah it has to be a
goddamn clue somewhere face this kid's
gonna die and I'm going around in
circles
basically youtuber actually tit
[Music]
Oh ready to go what are you talking
about investigations over we know who
did it we no longer need your services
anymore Norman so you can ride your
files all the way back to Washington I'd
be lying if I said I was gonna miss you
the investigation isn't over you have
absolutely nothing on Mars oh I wish
there was more of these they're so good
when you don't want to do homework but
physics is forcing your down into the
chair why is that funny
Jesus Christ me when thinking if I
should eat the last slice of pizza now
or save it for later that's where that
name is from I've seen it all the time
you see the stupid screenshot right
ahead
should I eat it now relate but if I ate
it and a half it's gonna be hot and
delicious I could save it for later as
man but if I eat it in Hayter then he
won't taste as good but I'm not really
that hungry now ah jeez oh my gosh it
looks like I'm already failing this
challenge hurry up
I must replenish my health with cheap
fuel
[Music]
oh well all my helpers back thanks Brad
I like a Brad Brad Brad Eason woulda
told me by GPO he's been wanting to get
sponsored by G field for so long an
income pewdiepie i entered the code
pewdiepie you're not getting a TG filled
Brad oh I'm not getting any G fuel
I'm not getting any G fuel me I'm okay
nej fuel I'm not getting any G fuel I'm
not getting any G fuel me come on man oh
my god yes they say they've been Cleo
would warn her about this seriously what
a bunch of muscles in the chat it's so
good why she crimes before everyone's
been pointing out how she sounds exactly
like a car alarm as well it's so good
moving on guys how are you doing don't
care let's keep going can I say it just
once before I come
yeah yeah bro Thanks no aha oh that's so
sad
can we sound like a car alarm now that's
actually sad whoa whoa what the frig it
keeps going
what okay that was pretty
they have a twin or am i stupid I can't
tell
no no no no no it's it's a it's a mirror
it's like a mayor that it's like a
memory trick I don't know I'm pretty
smart so the way they did it was like
mirrors I don't know if you heard of
those but that's how he did it basically
that's not like many of em or anything
like that
good joke okay I'm not really doing too
well on this challenge it would seem
that I it's time to G fuel up boy bet
you're jealous now Brad huh who's got a
G fuel sponsorship huh crying more
bright although to be fair bread you
just gotta enter the code P D pie and
you get 30% off that's a great deal
that's a good deal not saying the N word
for a 5 minute challenge it was clear
that Stein had receded at all and the
doctor offered up a suggestion no
hospital
it's the face that we all have to go
through to finally grow up and become a
man what is he actually doing I'm so
confused
this is my voice alright this is my
voice two years in California yes I mean
no that's horrible
yeah I feel like it's only funny have
you seen the reference and I'm not
showing the reference hit-or-miss
you got a boyfriend oh my god this is a
fake sadly Wow really must be some kind
of genius self-explanatory dream sound
right sorry what are you saying
self-explanatory dream sound
self-explanatory drink found one take
one okay
I love the gorilla laughter - it
actually worth this is what I means and
tick-tock were all invented to hold the
progression of humanity instead of
coming up with useful ideas that
progress humanity forward instead we
come up with this kind of stuff for the
sake of memes okay listen to me guys
you're gonna put on my tail tinfoil hat
memes was created by aliens
sounds crazy it was created to halt the
progression of mankind so that aliens
that lives far up in Dalian in galaxies
far away have time to reach us and
invade us so that by the time they reach
us our technology has not advanced at
all because all we did for a hundred
billion years was making means
think about it there's sand each other
the world right it's called that baby I
just be happy let's be watching boots so
much like on this video thank you very
much for watching make sure thank you
guys so much for watching I'll see you
guys holy you guys remember what I had
fifty seven thousand subscribers Jesus
all right
I'm famous I'm peds video yeah I did it
I did it
we made it we're out hit subscribe god
damn me I gotta you do yeah I got you
I'm sorry I'm sorry I was subscribed on
my seven other accounts that's great
hey shroud subscribing to your other
accounts god dammit
what are you call yourself a gamer huh
I'll keep checking
marciela per story you're like pac-man
you know what pack stands for program
and control his program and control man
the whole thing's a metaphor he thinks
he's got free will but really he's
trapped in a maze and assists them all
he can do is consume he's pursued by
demons that are probably just in his own
mind you hit a girl up with that line in
a club mm-hmm you better believe you be
swimming in pushed boy you'd be getting
so much push you can make a jackets out
of Puss you can make a whole fashion
clothing line out of Puss
that's how much push your beginning it's
either that or hit or miss there it is
there it is everyone the car alarms I
don't care what the price I make I get
high when you're stealing
that's the worst sense noise I have ever
heard
the really the passion into the
voice-acting incredible well i clearly
forgot about them your life who was
challenged again oh god what do I do
oh jeez I'm like million miles ahead
backwards it looks like I'm out of G
fuel oh my gosh darn it I'm gonna die
okay guys Petey pyres going to die but
remember all you have to do to save you
fight in for my always merge and G fuel
only for real gamers shroud you can't
have this okay
I bet shroud doesn't have a G fuel
that's it for its get that up see you
tomorrow for another video uh what's he
gonna upload then can't wait to find out
ah geez I see you I see you tomorrow
guys and as always remember to keep
dancing and smile
[Music]